this is sort of how I got started when I
was a teenager I was a musician I loved
rehearsing and I was working out the
songs together and I lovely cold in the
songs and then after the band I went to
university and I met my friend Steve who
had written a play and I auditioned for
a part in it it was the part of a
drunken but when you do a play and as
I'm sure you know there's a thing called
a technical rehearsal just before you
start where they work out the lighting
and things and you work out exactly
where to stand in relation to the lights
and you know when you're in the right
place because you feel the lights on
your eyelashes and I remember that
feeling and you feel as if everyone is
watching you which makes it sound like a
needle thing but it's not that it
there's a sense of the world being very
compressed and concentrated and things
having meaning so if you move you're
wrong in a play and everyone was kissing
with your home and everyone looks for
the meaning and that and if the play is
working there is meaning in that so so
with music I found this level
collaboration and in theater I'd found
this version of the world everything was
significant and where you could pretend
to be someone you weren't and dissolve
yourself and all of those things really
drew me so writing scripts was a place
for me where those different things came
together
it's strange that I entered that I
started writing in place because I
didn't really ever gone see places it
was a young person I still don't really
but I was brought up watching watching
movies at home
so I'd watch a lot of sort of black and
white Hollywood movies and then when I
was in my teens I guess I was watching
American indie movies so things like the
Coen brothers or ha Theo information and
then after that really quite Labor's I
discovering European cinema
I think Peter strong is one of our real
treasures actually he has that ability
to combine comedy and a real sense of
poetry so
the verse of that versatility is is
uncommon
original screenplays and adaptations
originals are harder not surprisingly
you have to come up with older the raw
material yourself but the interesting
thing is that the process of writing
both is is much more similar than you'd
think because even when you're adapting
someone else's work
you still haven't decide what you're
going to say with it and that's why I
sometimes wonder about the notion of a
faithful adaptation I think if you're
really writing as opposed to just going
through the motions then the script will
be being guided by your own
preoccupations and your own desires and
your own emotions you won't know it
because all this happens at a level that
you don't want to go to but every
decision you make will be completely
guided by this so I've adapted film
scripts from novels and novellas true
life stories documentaries other films
and plays of these you would think the
place would be the easiest source
material to adapt from and obviously the
pieces would be been conceived as drama
the characters are created the dialog is
already written but if I can give you
one piece of advice if any of you are
writers it's this thing very carefully
before trying to adapt the stage play to
the screen they come as friends but they
are secretly decisons and I think it's
because when something has existed in
one art form it's very strongly marked
by that form and it doesn't easily pass
over into another form so you know for
example you have to scrub all the
barnacles of the novel from the whole of
the story but a novel sort of appetizers
it's different from a screenplay and
you're forced to reimagine it as a film
from the very beginning a play comes
looking so much like a film script that
you can drop your guard and then you end
up with a recorded play no matter how
good the play was I don't think that can
make a satisfactory film the great
difficulty obviously we playwrights is
that they don't see cinematically but
Peter has one of those imaginations
whereby actually he sees an images
rather than in text and he works back
from the montage of those images and the
musicality of a film to construct the
story but always sort of you know
strives towards poetry and you know in a
way and and that felt about him to do
Tinker Tailor to try and create at the
poem of the book
something that would be much more
compressed and concentrated more vivid
but but smaller more elliptical but
somehow it would have the essence of the
book that boiled down where did you get
this
I didn't Percy and his little cabal
walked in with it
look controller style appalling patently
a fabrication from beginning to end just
could be the real thing glyph is genuine
is gorgeous but it's topicality makes it
suspect smiley is suspicious Percy where
did it come from
what's the access a new secret source of
mine but how could he possibly have
access it has access to the most
sensitive levels of policymaking even in
the operation witchcraft Percy and his
pals bypass that smiley gone straight to
the minister Percy has been allowed to
keep the identity of his new friend top
secret that's what some adaptations can
seem quite tricky everything a tailor
seemed tricky to get right you know it
seemed difficult to get right it wasn't
obviously unfilmable it had been a huge
TV adaptation we should be fighting
communism we've had enough it's going to
be changing we need to decide if we want
to be part of the past or part of the
future I should have left you where I
found you look
well I think if you look at what he did
with Tinker Tailor Soldier Spy you see
an incredibly effective piece of
thriller writing going alongside
wonderful character parts which enabled
these great actors and brought so many
of our greatest actors to all be
distinctive within the same within the
same film and I think that's a good
example of the versatility that he's got
on the surface most clips or dialogue
and not much else
I mean if there's some scene headings
little paragraphs describing basic
action but basically lots of lines of
dialogue and I think this conception of
the screenwriter is quite common that we
write the words and then directors come
and turn them into film and to image and
sound and that the script is an
important part the filmmaking process
but it's only a part the truth is I
think dialogue is possibly the least
important aspect of a script or at least
the surface of dialogue is the least
important Hitchcock said dialogue is
just one more sound in the film it just
happens to come out of people's mouths
and I think it's certainly true that if
a character is telling you what is going
on who they are as a person
what they're feeling what you should be
feeling if those things are present on
the surface and are only being delivered
by the surface then then you have
problems so the meaning of the film
isn't in what's being said it's in the
complicated and subtle play between
what's said and what isn't what's hidden
what's implied and can be inferred what
was accidentally said what was
deliberately said there's a net of words
and silence and dimension music but if
words dialogue words are all that's on
the page where is the rest of the film
and I think the answer to this is is in
structure
I think structure is one of those things
that you can and you know I think a lot
of people when they stop if they start
writing drama it's usually because they
have an ear for dialogue I think maybe
not everyone but for a lot of people I
think they have any epidemic and that's
what leads them to think they can they
can write scripts so some people just
have a kind of gift for that but I'm not
sure how many people have a natural
instinctive grasp of structure you know
I think that is something that you learn
but I think you'd probably then
instinctively and I think you learn it
by watching films and reading scripts
you just start to absorb the ways the
stories can be told on the stage he
learned how important compression and
meaning were and I think those are two
really significant skills that
screenwriting needs to learn that you
have to work out how to tell a story as
economically as possible
and to sort of dive to condense it into
something that's going to have impact
and leave a mark I think there's a
subtle tide in filmmaking and it does
flow in that direction the direction of
prediction and formula and you know and
you won't find many people who would
wholeheartedly endorse it but almost all
of us get drawn by that current to a
certain extent and that current makes us
begin believing the film should have a
certain structure and should have
certain plot beats and elements and
characters that should have backstories
that explain the situation and which
will end up being satisfactorily
resolved and I think worst of all as
audience members who are fed on a diet
of this we begin to expect that too and
instead of being open to stories that
work in a different way we feel baffled
or bored or absolutely insulted by them
I kind of feel you know the longer the
longer you're around and the most of
secure you begin to feel as a writer the
more you kind of start to pick and
choose to work so I kind of think that's
I'm hoping that's where I'm at now that
I would I think I'm feeling creasing
interested in trying to tell stories
that are a little more off the beaten
track and I don't necessarily mean that
there wouldn't be drama movies but just
at the treatment table I suppose I just
feel inspired much more by those kind of
movies now and I suppose that's the way
that's there's I'd like to go in so we
reached the point where we can only
digest stories that tell us things we've
already been told and that has to be
ante out Samuel Johnson said about
artists that their greatest ability was
to make new things familiar unfamiliar
things new
and here's another aphorism be ignorant
of what you're going to catch as a
fisherman of what is at the end of his
fishing rod the fish that arises from
nowhere and you know it's obvious why
the film industry as an industry would
want to find ways of predicting and
controlling the success of a story with
an audience and I understand why they
wanted to invite him into a
and I understand it because I want to -
and when I looked at the screenwriting
software site to see what software I
could come then I did 32 characters that
might be quite useful but you know so we
all want as much of shortcuts and but I
do think it's a mistake I'm Sergeant 1st
class Lyn Cassady Special Forces retired
in the 80s I was trained at Fort Bragg
under a secret initiative codenamed
project Jedi the objective of the
project was to create super soldiers
soldiers with superpowers we were the
first generation of the new earth army
you've got super powers that's correct
wait what you're saying is that you were
a psychic spy like lacy we prefer the
term remote viewer how does that work
well different Jedi had different
techniques Mel Landau used to visualize
packing all this troubles into a little
suitcase to clear his mind
Steve Tuttle would recite Bible verse
which is what about you I find I find
reiki help because filmmakers don't have
to imitate the appearance of people or
objects you know as painters with a
scope this wood or a novelist wood and
we have machines that do that we have
cameras and sound because to do that all
we have to do all we can do is choose
the bits and then decide where to make
the knots that tie them together and I
think this is where poetry becomes
possible not in a single scene but in
the combined effect of the scene that
came before and the scene that came
after and this is where the emotional
effect of cinema lies not in the shot of
the actor crying as hard as he or she
can but in the combination of the shot
of the actor crying and the shot which
preceded or follows that shot and if
this sounds obvious it is but if it
sounds easy it isn't because the choices
are infinite the road you can take folks
and folks again and it's much easier to
get lost than to find a way through it's
very interesting because I know some
writers who just want to get the first
draft oh and they just want to get from
the beginning to the end and they know
that it's it's very rough
but it just feel they have to do it our
way and then begins the process of
redrafting and polishing and gradually
improving it improving it gets there and
I never I can't work that way I'm I
always I'm trying to sort of the first
draft always feels like it has to be the
shooting draft I never raised obviously
you do then continue to draft but I hate
that feeling of moving on feeling like
the bridge isn't complete behind you you
know you kind of want to feel like no
it's solid all the way behind me it's
solid and obviously it isn't but you I
need to feel as if it is you know see I
need to be working I can't just be
sketching I can't sketch it I have to be
painting it in as I'm going even if that
that means you have to redo it we paint
over the top of him paint over the top
of it David Mamet's had a sign on his
desk which he'd borrowed from Clinton's
presidential campaign team and it read
keep it simple stupid but simplicity
shouldn't be and can't be the starting
point instead you start with this great
mass of material all of these
possibilities simplicity is the end
product of moving through all those
choices it's the reward for all your
hard work
empty the pond to get the fish he knows
what he wants to do he can see the film
that he wants to write or has written
and yet he's so willing and open to
having what he's done lifted into
another layer and onto another level by
a good director or the contribution of a
producer or an actor so he he is that
rare combination of a pleasure to work
with and a uniquely talented individual
when the novel was invented and it
wasn't just a new way of articulating
the way we experience the world it
created new ways of experiencing and
feeling about the world and the same is
true of cinema as best on set it's it's
a new way of writing and it brings the
possibility of new ways of feeling so if
I think about the feelings that were
created by that last shot just as an
example of truth was 400 blows had they
ever been felt before the French
new-wave for Italian new realism or
American cinema the 70s didn't so much
reflect the way things were in the world
has create new ways of relating to it
and I know this sounds a little grand
and might seem a long way from you know
someone who probably be working on the
wrong
through that next year and it seems to
sit more easily with you know so-called
art house cinema but I don't think that
high rock is very useful if we think of
a Billy Wilder rom-com or was thriller
by Melville or Jacques Audiard or ben
wheatley and these are films that forget
their rom-coms and Phyllis genre is just
the rhythm section and music that can be
endlessly varied and inventive so I
think this is what film writing can be
and you know obviously I hope that goes
our saying I'm not making frames here
for my own work this is just
aspirational stuff I'll come good it's
it's a structuring of events that
creates poetry allows us to see
something the world we wouldn't
otherwise have seen allows us to feel in
a new way and feeling is a kind of
thinking and I think I've ended up
talking about filmmaking as a whole
rather than specifically screenwriting
but I think that's natural for a
screenwriter to do because filmmaking is
an odd and sort of wasteful process and
the work that the screenwriter does ends
up being just the fossil of an active
imagination and it will all have to be
written all over again in the filming no
matter how great the script the actual
film will only be a distant relative of
it it will never be an identical twin
think you know there's a lot of
questions about because my wife Bridget
was sometimes work with and was a writer
as well died just before tinker Taylors
made and I think there's a lot of
questions about what it's like to write
without her that I still don't quite
know the answer to she died two years
ago
and I didn't write anything in the first
year at all and and even the last year
the second year when he very gladly sort
of groped my way back towards writing
and I think if first if Li I mean I did
wonder if I was going to be able to do
it again because you know writing
obviously does come from an emotional
aspect of yourself and my emotions were
sort of so until more that I felt maybe
I wasn't gonna be able to do it but now
it's reached the point where I think
it's a it's a it's a comfort clearly
they were a fantastic the Russian
partnership and that they complemented
each other
but he had the generosity to say that
she was the ideas monkey and he was the
craftsman and that he was there just to
provide structure whereas she was the
one who could always fly where where he
was earthbound now I don't think that's
true Peters work I think the work that
he's done on his own shows that he is a
fantastically imaginative and versatile
screenwriter but it gives you a sense of
the man really he has that humility that
honesty that Romanticism he brings to
all of his work and he's very very happy
to share that credit with anyone else
who he's involved with I'm still I'm
still trying to work out what it's like
to write without him because I used to
always go to Bridget for you know to
read something or to get advice and she
was much more of a writer than I I mean
it feels much more inventive she could
just endlessly come up with ideas and
proxy scene ideas you know if you were
if you'd painted yourself the corner she
could always think her way out and I
don't have that really I think I've
probably better with its structure you
know I had a more sort of editorial mind
and she was much more freewheeling so it
sort of felt like a good combination I
would keep her in check and she would
stop me from becoming obvious and I
think to a certain extent probably what
I've done this is sort of internalized
her voice so I kind of do still Alaska
to have a look at it and I do sort of
try and listen see would we be should
have thought that was right or not you
know so I guess that still happiness in
some level the script is what's left
over from a film that you had in your
head and it's in it's a failure but
almost is a bad product from that can
come a different film the film that will
be made from the script but it is very
tangentially related to the film that
you have in your head you know so for
the writer the film was already made so
to conclude by return to that question
what does the screenwriter do I'd rather
answer by saying what it feels like we
do in this context I don't want to claim
a little more of the film as being my
responsibility I don't want to accept
the script as a valuable but limited
part of the process of making the film I
want to say that it is the film
Paul Schrader said a screenplay is not a
work of art it's an invitation to
collaborate in the creation of a work of
art and I know this is true we don't
queue up and buy tickets to walk into a
cinema and leave through a script and
I'm not making the usual gripe to the
writers make about not being appreciated
enough I'm just saying it isn't how I'll
experience right in a film it is what it
feels like when I'm writing a film when
I'm sitting down and start typing I
don't feel that I'm writing an
invitation for collaboration I don't
feel like I'm writing a blueprint or an
instruction manual and when it's really
working I don't feel like I'm writing a
screenplay I feel that I'm transcribing
a film that I'm watching and it's the
whole film all the images the sounds the
music I made the whole film it's just I
was the only one who got to see it
you